Machine learning can change people's
lives through medical diagnosis.
Machine learning
can improve traffic.
I've built models
even to find out
who had scored more goals
in soccer championships.
My name is Anderson Luis Amaral.
I'm currently the CDO -
Chief Data Officer - at Dataholics.
I work as the company's
data scientist.
I also build models
using machine learning.
I'm from Pindamonhangaba,
in São Paulo's countryside.
I was raised both there
and in the capital.
I didn't know which career
to pursue when I was young.
I always enjoyed looking at data.
I was a very curious kid.
I had to find a way
of channeling that.
I worked with technology, IT,
and software development,
but there was still
something missing.
I have no problem admitting
I was only an average developer.
I wasn't extraordinary.
I wouldn't even consider myself
a senior developer, far from it.
I took an interest in machine learning,
but I knew little about it.
I didn't know where to start.
I started studying on my own
and signed up for the Udacity programs.
As soon as I entered
the field of data science,
I saw a huge difference,
as I became highly sought-after.
I was truly impressed.
It was huge. I was getting
job offers every single day.
When I met the people
at Dataholics,
they had been operating
as a data mining company.
They would perform data mining,
but would not build any models
based on those data.
So we sat down and came up
with the machine learning services
that are now the company's
main product.
When Anderson joined our team,
not only did we go from a company
that provided data
to one that provided intelligence,
but we also underwent big changes.
He actually implemented
this machine-learning technology.
That's why I'm a partner now.
He started behind the scenes
and took center stage.
That's what really
happened to him.
For the last 4 months, we've won,
on average, one prize per month.
Demand for our products
is so high at the moment
that we're struggling
to meet it.
If there was anything
I could change,
I probably would've studied
machine learning earlier
and would've put it into practice
in my previous jobs,
because you see surprising results
very quickly
and you have answers
that only data could give you.